hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar XP 293 new tools for structural
biology and difficult to express
proteins presented by dr. John's muda
director cell biology Life Sciences
solutions group Thermo Fisher Scientific
I'm Christie jewel of lab routes and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
this presentation is brought to you by
lab roots and sponsored by thermo Fisher
Scientific for more information on our
sponsor please visit thermo Fisher com
this presentation you are about to see
was previously recorded but I would like
to remind you that this event is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send doctors amudha will
be answering questions via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
I would now like to introduce today's
presenter dr. John Simona dr. zmuda is a
director of cell biology at Thermo
Fisher Scientific in Frederick Maryland
John leads a team dedicated to
discovering and developing new
technologies and products useful for
cell biology applications including
transient protein expression advanced
cell culture and rare cell analysis he
received his PhD in cell biology from
the University of Maryland College Park
dr. zmuda will now begin his
presentation
today I'd like to talk about some of the
new tools that we've developed at thermo
Fisher focusing a little bit on XP to 93
but because insect cells seem to be
having a bit of a resurgence at this
conference I'm not afraid to put in a
few slides on our ex BSF chemically
defined insects system as well and some
of the new application data that we've
generated within that system so just a
quick reminder about seven or eight
years ago when I joined thermo our
vision really was to provide these first
generation high expressing transient
systems across the the three most
typical cell lines for protein
expression x bt 9 3 exp cho and and of
course the XP to 93 has been a workhorse
system for many labs or for many years
this is obviously based on a high
expressing 293 F cell variant and
typically we can see antibody yields to
about a gram per liter and XP to 93 in
about five days with a lot of anybody's
expressing about 100 to hundreds of per
meter range but really again what you
see is this broad animal proteins
expressed in the 290 so so it's really
the system's rate R and allow the
screening reagent or enumeration for
structural biology applications membrane
and intracellular proteins and really as
of the last you know decade or so moving
into a AV and went to virus production
as well as the predominant host for for
those viruses who so much in fairly XP
Cho has has been an absolute workhorse
for antibodies anything with NFC in FTE
infusion despite specifics multi
specific antibodies has a choice of many
researchers and then the X BSF system on
the insect side of things often ate a
great alternative to either of the two
mammalian system so again part of our
paradigm goes up we'd be able to get
high levels of expression of any
protein regardless of whether it
expressed well in one or all of the
systems and so for the insect system
there's certainly there is a play for
intracellular proteins proteins that are
toxic to mammalian cells as well as
vaccines VLPs and also a production
insect cells are SF 9s are quite popular
today as well so what I'd like to do is
just introduce you to some of the new
tools that we've developed for xB 293
over the last year twenty twenty
nineteen we launched a number of these
reagents particularly focus for
structural biology but certainly having
overlapping functionality for other
protein expression tasks as well and so
what we'll talk a little bit about today
I'll just will introduce the fact that
we do have cgmp banked x b-29 three it's
cells that are available for licensing
for both protein or or virus production
and then within our x b-29 three
structural biology module we've launched
a three new cell lines so all based on
the high expressing XB 293 parental line
the gmt one negative cell line that
kenny spoke of earlier today and an xB
293 inducible cell line for modulating
your protein expression as well as a
combination inducible GN ti- line that's
popular for many membrane protein
researchers as as well as lastly the
finding efficient transmission and
labeling kits so really the our first
foray into doing metabolic labeling
within these high expressing mammalian
protein expression systems so just to go
through the xB 293 GMT one negative cell
line as mentioned previously this is a
knock out of the GMT one enzyme that
prevents the cells from going from this
high menos or mem 5 glycol form to the
more complex forms of glycans and what
we see here is that this cell line this
GMT I knockout retains essentially all
of the expression potential of the
parental xB 293 cell line and when we
compare that to the ATCC GMT one
knockout cell lines that have been a
suspension adapted into freestyle media
is quite common in the literature we see
about a 30 fold improvement in protein
titers compared to the ATCC cells which
also tend to be fairly clumpy and a
little bit less easy to handle whereas
all of the xb2 9-3 derived cell lines
that I'll talk to you today have very
similar growth characteristics as the
parental line and what you see on the
bottom left is just looking at the
glycan profiles for native IgG expressed
in the xb9 3 system where we have a
pretty typical mixture of the g0 f and g
1f g 2f glycans when you take a look at
the same material expressed in the GN t
1 knockouts we have essentially
exclusive man v glyco forms as expected
and one really beautiful representation
of native x b-29 3 cells and to the
right of that and the GM t1 knockouts
where you get this very beautiful
homogeneous band of glycan regulated
protein and this actually has two
different functions one as certainly as
Ken called out earlier today for
structural biology applications it's
ideal to either have homogenous small
glycans or the ability to very easily
release those and completely release
those with pngs pngs F for example and
secondarily this work done with a
collaborator collaborator at the NIH
also indicated that purification of
these proteins of this particular GPCR
was much easier when we had this
homogenous glycosylation pattern so
these cell lines do a really great job
at controlling that glycosylated
also keeping very high expression levels
then jumping over to our xB 293
inducible cell line so this is a cell
line made with sort of the
tried-and-true tech repressor technology
where it's the cell line has been stable
e generated to express very high levels
of the tet repressor protein so when
when you have the xB 293 inducible line
you simply then need to made it to one
of our tet on plasmids so p c d and a
four or five t over
there's and then that will allow you to
have control of your protein expression
with the addition of tet and you can see
that on the upper right in fact using a
gfp fused cb2 gpcr membrane protein that
you can modulate the expression level of
the protein quite nicely through the
addition of different concentrations of
tet so similar in a manner which in the
past had had used filler DNA to to cut
the amount of plasmid DNA single step in
terms of the titration of your
tetracycline on the bottom you can see
representative images so we have a very
low background from the inducible cells
when they're in the absence of tet you
can see maybe a couple cells in here
that that are fluorescent green but very
high expression levels and potentially
even with some sub cloning this could
this could come down even further but
again looking at a comparison to the
existing t-rex 290 310 inducible cell
line we've got almost a tenfold
improvement compared to that cell line
and again when we fully induce these
cells we're as good or even slightly
better than the parental xB 293 cells so
a lot of potential there's a lot of
different reasons that one may want to
use an inducible cell line certainly
I'll show some case studies on membrane
proteins where it is proven to be able
to significantly improve the expression
levels of some of these membrane
proteins and again just looking at
another guy again cherry expression
again very tightly regulated in the
absence of induction very strong
fluorescence in the parental or the
fully induced cells and then the
combination of these cell lines so based
off of the GNT one negative line we then
made that double mutant so that we have
induce ability again control of a
glidecam modulated cell line so again
essentially a single peak at at Man 5
where we expect it to be and again
comparing the dual mutant the inducible
GN ti- cell compared to t-rex we've got
about an Eightfold improvement in terms
of induce ability and these cells
actually the
the background here is is even a little
bit more tightly controlled than the the
single mutant again showing very nice
modulation of signal GFP cb2 in this
case with the dose of tetracycline added
and then lastly from the the new
reagents is the Athenian efficient xB
293 labeling system so this is of course
it's just a single amino acid deficient
so there is still some limitations in
the applicability of a single amino acid
but it is a first step in terms of being
able to do these high titer expressions
with a metabolic label we we've
generated data either using a 13 C
methionine variant or Selena methionine
both very common in the structural
biology world for NMR for example for
the 13 C methionine you can the cells
really don't know that they're in it
they grow perfectly fine you can employ
any number of strategies to label your
cells by either passing them continually
in the 13 C which could get a little bit
expensive or simply we've also done x 0
where you just spin the cells down wash
them or replace the the media and you
can still get very high 90 95 %
incorporation ratio of your 13 C Metheny
solely no math I need a little bit
different story it's well known that
that's fairly toxic to cells so we do
take a a significant hit on tighter but
if this is compared to some of the
legacy systems where those titers would
be close to 0 200 200 milliliters still
quite good so again you know taking a
significant hit but still being able to
have a fair amount of protein there in
the case of so we know methionine the
cells cannot be maintained or cultured
in that so we we employ typically a spin
down will starve the cells in the
Metheny deficient media and then simply
add back the Sonoma thiamine at the time
of transfection so that the cells can
incorporate that into their into their
protein and shown below is just a mass
spec representation of the the native
peptide at 9 9 17.9
with the Selina Matheny the molecular
weight shift of that particular pen side
so I'm just going to go into some a
couple case studies membrane proteins
are obviously a hot topic out there
GPCRs there's about close to 900 of them
and about 30 to 40% of drugs that are
approved today targeted gpcr in one form
or another only a few of them have had
their structure solved and so there's a
lot of interest in expressing GPCRs but
there are certainly drawbacks to doing
so in bacterial systems that have
traditionally been employed especially
the lack of the post translational
modifications that through some of our
collaborations and and hopeful
publications in 2020 will will show the
importance of having mammalian post
translational modifications on certain
properties of these gpcr proteins that
that may be going overlooked when we're
expressing them in the in the
prokaryotic systems but I just wanted to
start with one case study this is GPCR a
a 2 AR it's a adenosine receptor and I'm
going to show data for expression of
this and the ex b-29 three parental
cells the GMT one negative cells as well
as XP ciao actually I'm not going to
focus too much on ex bicho in these
presentations as I'll show you in a
couple slides the 2 9 3 cells seem to do
a great job of expressing membrane
proteins the cho cells seem to really
like expressing antibodies they don't do
as well in protein there's a lot of
different considerations you need to
take when you're setting up in
determining optimal expression
conditions and in fact I'm only showing
a subset of them here but in this case
we have a 2 a are fused to G directly
fused to gfp and a hist AG on the
c-terminus and we find that this
generally does a good job of helping to
establish optimal conditions for the
expression of your GPCRs with one
exception is that you have to watch out
for the optimal harvest time because i
GFP will tend to sort of diminish
in fluorescence past about 48 hours in
the cells
whereas if you then look to express and
purify the non GFP version of the
protein you probably have a little bit
of a wider window so for example 48 to
72 hours is often the sweet spot for
most of these proteins if you look at
the GFP related fluorescence by 72 hours
it starts to come down significantly but
aside from that it's been a fairly good
a fairly good marker for optimizing
protein membrane protein expression and
typically the the gpcrs that we've
expressed with it linked to have
retained their activity as well so just
here we're showing looking at different
doses of DNA and different
concentrations of our enhancers 1 & 2
enhancer 2 for X B Cho would be the X
bgo feed but we looked at modulating all
of these different conditions to
identify the the optimal parameters for
this particular GPCR and without going
into all the bars here what we're seeing
on the the x axis is the plasma DNA
concentration from 0.25 to 1/2 of my
program to one microgram per milk and
then with no enhancer one with half of
the recommended volume with a hundred
percent and with 150 percent so these
conditions here actually represent the X
b-29 3 catalog conditions so they they
work quite well for both gpcrs as well
as your typical secreted or
intracellular proteins and here we've
assessed the expression levels by flow
cytometry after 48 hours and what we've
seen with the parental x meet i'm sorry
with the XP to 93 GMT 1 - cells is that
we had better expression when we were
using relatively higher for normal
levels of DNA at about a microgram per
mil as well as the presence of the the
enhancer want to boost expression
consistent with what we have in our
catalog recommendations now with the
y-axis being the same
this is XP Cho for this particular DBC
are so very much about portal reduce
expression
GPCR and it's independent of how long we
let the X be Cho cultures go out so
these are representative of the highest
expression level that we saw in the XP
Cho cells compared to the exp 293 cells
so again I think this is this you know
continues to confirm our thought process
and recommendations around X b-29 3 as
being a very good cell line for
expression of membrane proteins so if we
look at some of these optimized
conditions so we went through the xB 293
GMT 1 where we showed that using higher
or a more standard amount of DNA so one
one big four mil coupled with a hundred
percent of the the enhancer from the
expression system gives us the the
highest expression levels and in
contrast however for the parental xB 293
cells we see it's actually a bit
flip-flop than that the parental cells
can't handle as much expression of this
GPCR so we actually lower the DNA amount
to get the highest titers from the x
b-29 3 cells as we go up to a microgram
per mil we actually lose expression of
the of the gpcr and again the you know
these GM ti- and inducible cells are
clonal derivatives of xB to 93 and we do
know that there is and then again next
week show of the same y-axis and what we
found though is that it actually is
beneficial to just go ahead and express
this proteins without any of the feed
it's really not necessary to go for 48
hours and that will give you the best
conditions and then I mentioned some of
the work we've done with the inducible
cell line so what are our strategy for
the toxic proteins or some of these
membrane proteins for example where you
really want to bulk up your bio mess to
get as much protein as you can so we
looked at transfecting the X b-29 3
cells and then you know adding enhancer
1 and 2 as expected and then harvesting
at 48 or 72
and then we did a 40 inducible line we
transfected and we and we added the tet
as well as the feed-in enhancer at the
typical 22 hour time point or in green
we held off one extra day and we allowed
the cells to bulk up in terms of their
density and then we added the enhancers
and and the induction at 48 hours and
what you can see is again firstly
looking at this drop from from 48 to 72
hours I think that's what I have
mentioned earlier tends to be an
artifact of the GFP more than the
expression of the protein but what we
found is that in multiple cases and from
the last slide what I was showing here
we got almost a four-fold improvement in
the amount of membrane protein expressed
and for two other GPCRs we had about a
one and a half or 1.6 X fold improvement
by employing this later induction
strategy and what you can see is that
when we run the standard protocol these
cells at the time of addition of the
enhancers or and induction we were at
about 6 million so the cells roughly
double from 3 million to 6 million in
the case of the ones where we held off
and induce later we were almost double
right around double the cell density so
certainly some of this improvement in
expression is based simply on biomass
but in terms of membrane proteins that
are expressing in very low
concentrations the more biomass you can
have in a small volume the more
cost-effective your reactions are and
just to give you an example for some of
these GPCR cb2 that we've done work for
you know we've typically had what are
considered to be very good titers in the
structural biology community somewhere
in the 3 to 4 Mick per liter purified
range for the for some of these gpcrs so
getting actually quite good expression
levels with with some of these clones in
the system and so now I'll go into one
other case study very similarly this is
for optimized expression of ion channels
this is the KCC to ion channel and again
this goes into a little
more detail this is work that we did
with collaborators and at collects art
in Lyon France and here you see it's a
much more detailed optimization where
we've looked at two different vectors so
CMV and an ef-1 alpha promoter different
DNA amounts different cell lines
different temperatures and the and the
purification tags on either the the NRC
terminus of the protein and you can see
you know quite quite dramatic
differences in these gels depending on
all of these conditions and and where we
landed again we did not see great
expression out of the xB Cho cells but
we our best conditions ended up being
the X b-29 3 system with our we use the
PC DNA 5 teo vector just to give us
flexibility to potentially couple that
with the inducible cell lines in later
slides and in the case of this receptor
shifting down to 32 c was was most
beneficial so again each one of these
membrane proteins really you know needs
to be looked at in its own and
conditions optimized for it but these
are some some nice eeehm data from
purified KCC - that exists both as a
dimer and a monomer and you can see some
of these monomers and and dimers in the
e/m graphs and you can see that on the
s-e-c as well but what we ended up with
was very nice aggregate free KCC - that
was able to be concentrated well for
downstream structural biology studies
while xB Cho expressed much lower the
quality of the protein was still quite
good and we also did this saw similar
results for a sodium channel as well
that we tested side by side another
example of the GMT eye- cells so you can
see the the difference in how they run
on these gels again in a number of these
bands the the high and low glycosylation
indicative of the GMT one negative cell
line again protein quality was very good
for that cell line as well as for the
tet inducible cells where you can see no
tet and then titration of tet induction
and KCC - signal going up
and lastly these are just some early
data of work that we've been doing in
our lab to boost expression levels of
our membrane proteins and this was just
some internal development work that that
we have ongoing right now where we were
able to increase the expression levels
four to five fold of case ec2 compared
to the parental xB 293 system which for
the structural biology world is is
actually a you know quite quite a feat
because again every every fold that you
have a protein improvement in these very
low expressing proteins means the
systems become more cost effective for
the for the researchers so we'll take
just a few minutes to go through a
couple slides on the the X BSF
expression system so this is an SF 9
based insect system it it utilizes the
first chemically defined insect media
for high titer production of proteins in
insects cells and like all of our XP
systems it's built along the premise of
combining different reagents together
optimizing them in a systematic approach
so that we get synergistic benefit of of
protein yield from the systems and I
think very similar as Sabine called out
earlier today one of the other hallmarks
of this system is we have a transfection
reagent to do highly efficient
suspension transfection of our back mid
such that we make p 0 virus we can make
large quantities of p 0 virus that's
very good for protein expression and you
can go right into an expression run the
other thing that's quite interesting as
well is that while you're making your p
0 virus it's such an efficient
amplification of virus and you're also
making your protein of interest so you
actually have an opportunity to look at
your protein of interest from this same
flask that you're making your p 0 virus
to get some indication on whether it's
going to express well or not in in the
insect cells so again taking this from
you know 12 to 20 days you know down to
6 to 10 days and I think in the insect
systems because of the upfront labor and
making the viruses any days that can be
chopped off of that workflow are
are very valuable so just some some
quick performance data for proteins and
cell growth so this is the xB s f9 cells
these cells are very high density they
will grow to 20 million cells per mil in
a shake flask so almost as high as the
cho cells and you can see just a
representation of the comparison to all
of the different insect and a panel of
different insect media that are all
yeast elate containing so we've got very
very good growth of the cells compared
to them and just three proteins that we
show here compared to all of the
existing panel of East LA containing
media versus the XPS F system for these
three proteins three four five fold
improvements please you know visit our
poster later to get more details on that
and and again GPC our expression in
insects cells also quite quite common in
this case we had about a tenfold
improvement in the x BSF the high
density system compared to a traditional
SF 902 workflow so we were able to get
very good expression of membrane
proteins and what's new with the XPS F
system so for large scale as I mentioned
previously for vaccines VLPs AAV vacuole
viruses is of significant interest to
manufacturer so we do have an A GT
version so a advanced granulation
technology version of the media for for
scale-up we talked a little bit earlier
today about scalability of the insect
systems we've generated some data 10
liter run in a twenty two liter wave bag
compared to shake glass and these cells
and the system itself work quite well so
we've got very similar growth kinetics
in the shake flash versus the wave bag
we tend to see that the weight bag
usually lags about a day behind in terms
of tighter and and some of the kinetics
compared to the shake flash but for for
two proteins you can see here we've
actually got quite similar and
respectable loss of titer minimal loss
of tighter in the weight bag compared to
the shake flasks and then lastly some
data of the XPS FSS
adapted into a 2-liter stirred-tank
bioreactor for expressing AAV again we
see very similar trends between the
shake flasks in red the bio reactors in
blue for VCD viability cell size we get
very nice expression of our AAV and and
the representative proteins here looking
at a standard low density 900 2 or 3
protocol compared to the XPS F system
very significant improvements in AAV
titers and our AAV is effective on
unsusceptible cells in this case
recombinant AAV 2 and again much more
information at our poster and lastly
I'll wrap up just in terms of some
examples of enveloped and non envelope
VLPs in the XPS F system again compared
to our traditional system very
significant fold improvements for these
proteins but I will certainly say as was
mentioned earlier today the the insect
expression world is much more of the
Wild West so everybody has their best
cells their best media their best virus
and it depends on which cells you make
your which cells you use to make your
virus in which media the combinations
are really daunting and it and I and I
feel for the speaker earlier today
because it is very difficult to really
get a good competitive assessment on on
different insects systems because of all
the variables it's it's much more much
trickier than than with the transients
and you're you're relatively well
defined plasmid DNA
lastly I'll wrap up we've got three
posters here today it's 40 45 46 47 one
focusing on xB Cho 2 9 3 one focusing on
the membrane proteins what we talked
about today as well as the X BSF system
and with that I just like to wrap up and
and thank broad panel of people all of
the the R&D team that's not in Canada
that's had paste in Maryland as well as
the folks that have helped the
purification the analytical Henry and
Natasha who are here today please you
know if you have a chance I'm sure many
of you know both
them our field application scientists
Matt McKenna is here as well provides
excellent scientific support across the
East Coast and our colleagues at
collects are in Lyon for the KCC too and
and nav 1.6 collaboration studies and
with that I think I'm right on time
Carlos so I will wrap up and and thank
you very much for your attention today
[Applause]
you
a big thank you goes out to dr. Jones
the Buddha for his excellent
presentation now if you do have any
questions you would like to ask dr.
zmuda please type them in the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
dr. zmuda will be answering questions
via the email address you provided at
the time of registration
I would also like to thank laberd's and
our sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event
that's all for now and we hope to see
you again soon have a great day